are there some fundamental principles of
gripping that you can speak to
like what the hell is gripping
gripping is having the ability to
hold your opponent in such a way where
you have the ability to be offensive and
also the ability to be defensive at the
same given time
and
it's a distinction because i can hold
you in such a way where
i might be able to feel offensive but if
you can take a purely defensive grip and
then i can't be offensive we are no
longer gripping we are holding each
other
right
right so like
that would be the act of being able to
grip is to be in a situation where you
have me and i have you and i can play
both offense and defense at the same
time where you can only play defense
so donahue talks about like jiu jitsu
that way and not that way but maybe you
can see if there's a distinction
so you have a set of weapons the other
person has a set of weapons you want to
sort of maximize the use of your weapons
and shut down
the set of weapons that they have that
they have you see gripping the same way
on the on the feet
i do if we want to include body
positioning with our gripping
right okay because i can give you any
grip you want and you still can't throw
me because i can put myself in a
position
that nullifies your ability to use those
grips in a successful way
and those um would you say the hips are
critical to that or is it a thing hips
shoulders chin position head position
you know the angle of your foot yeah
yeah where you lean
wow okay and so uh and there's a bunch
of places you can grip obviously if
people like kind of think of a jacket
like there's a bunch of places you can
grip that are interesting so you can
grip on the collar you can grip on the
sleeves you can grip like at the elbow
joint yep and then you could do uh those
badass like
eastern european georgian or back back
over the opposite sides of the heads
yeah yeah the koreans that grab on one
side around the head with their hands
together yeah there's something really
nice about just those like i mean
especially george just throwing that
hand yeah just over the person and just
it's you're not actually gripping a belt
or anything you're gripping just the
entirety of like as opposed to being all
nice so i'm gonna grab this part of the
jacket this part of the jacket you're
just like taking the whole [ __ ]
jacket
and just launching somebody for those
people that can't picture
judo think about it in like if you
understood like what a boxing match
looks like
and you thought about that as like
traditional gripping
when you throw like a russian grip over
the back that's more like a hockey fight
like i'm just grabbing you and we're
just gonna
we're gonna be throwing punches left and
right because when we have that grip
somebody has to get thrown yeah there's
no there's no we don't walk around with
this grip it's it's go time once
somebody throws it
to me as a as a fan and sort of amateur
practitioner
there's two styles of olympic level judo
one is where you're trying not to get
thrown
and the other is where you're trying to
throw
uh
more specifically when you're trying not
to get thrown there's like the strategy
they're using gripping to
nullify their offense and all those
kinds of stuff you're you're being very
clever and strategic and all that you
know maybe using conditioning
and then there's people who just like
step in the pocket
and they don't almost don't care if
they're getting thrown because they have
the confidence that they're going to
throw first yep and those like there's a
clear distinction between the people
that do one or the other and i think
both can be done extremely successfully
at the highest level it's just like
obviously you admire the people that
step in the pocket and and i think when
you look at the people who do judo
the best like if we want to talk about
like
the top 10 percent of the people who
would compete at the games
they do both
and they do both
really well but they favor one
because
if you look at a player like uh
lutetiliani of georgia for example
there's a guy that stands in the pocket
but we can find numerous occasions where
he's hustled some people for like a
short period of time to get out of
scenarios to
elongate the match to make somebody
tired
so you want both sides of the coin
but you better pick the one that
you know eighty percent of your strategy
is going to be built around
you